we all use smartphones but have you ever
wondered how much data it generates in
the form of texts
phone calls emails photos videos
searches and music approximately 40
exabytes of data gets generated every
month
by a single smartphone user now imagine
this number multiplied by 5 billion
smartphone users
that's a lot for our mind even process
isn't it
in fact this amount of data is quite a
lot for traditional computing systems to
handle
and this massive amount of data is what
we term as
big data let's have a look at the data
generated per minute on the internet
2.1 million snaps are shared on snapchat
3.8 million search queries are made on
google
one million people log on to facebook
4.5 million videos are watched on
youtube
188 million emails are sent
that's a lot of data so how do you
classify any
data as big data this is possible with
the concept of
five v's volume velocity
variety veracity and value
let us understand this with an example
from the health care industry
hospitals and clinics across the world
generate massive
volumes of data 2 314
exabytes of data are collected annually
in the form of patient records and test
results
all this data is generated at a very
high speed which attributes to the
velocity of big data
variety refers to the various data types
such as structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
examples include
excel records log files and x-ray images
accuracy and trustworthiness of the
generated data is termed as
veracity analyzing all this data will
benefit the medical sector by enabling
faster disease detection
better treatment and reduced cost
this is known as the value of big data
but how do we store and process this big
data
to do this job we have various
frameworks such as cassandra
hadoop and spark let us take hadoop as
an example
and see how hadoop stores and processes
big data
hadoop uses a distributed file system
known as hadoop distributed file system
to store big data if you have a huge
file your file will be broken down into
smaller chunks
and stored in various machines not only
that when you break the file
you also make copies of it which goes
into different nodes
this way you store your big data in a
distributed way
and make sure that even if one machine
fails your data is safe on another
mapreduce technique is used to process
big data
a lengthy task a is broken into smaller
tasks
b c and d now instead of one machine
three machines take up each task and
complete it in a parallel fashion
and assemble the results at the end
thanks to this the processing becomes
easy and fast this is known as parallel
processing
now that we have stored and processed
our big data we can
analyze this data for numerous
applications
in games like halo 3 and call of duty
designers analyze user data to
understand at which stage most of the
users pause
restart or quit playing this insight can
help them rework on the story line of
the game
and improve the user experience which in
turn reduces the customer churn rate
similarly big data also helped with
disaster management during hurricane
sandy in 2012
it was used to gain a better
understanding of the storm's effect on
the east coast of the u.s
and necessary measures were taken it
could predict the hurricane's landfall
five days in advance
which wasn't possible earlier these are
some of the clear indications of how
valuable big data can be
once it is accurately processed and
analyzed
so here's a question for you which of
the following statements is not correct
about hadoop distributed file system
hdfs a hdfs
is the storage layer of hadoop b data
gets stored in a distributed manner in
hdfs
c hdfs performs parallel processing of
data
d smaller chunks of data are stored on
multiple data nodes in
hdfs give it a thought and leave your
answers in the comment section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
now that you have learned what big data
is what do you think will be the most
significant
impact of big data in the future let us
know in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video it would only
take a few seconds to like and share it
also to subscribe to our channel if you
haven't yet and hit the bell icon to get
instant notifications about our new
content
stay tuned and keep learning
you